[Music]
I'm surprised that anything came out I
was trying not to cry the whole time
[Music]
I want to know how you're feeling after
laying out all those emotions that's how
I feel like is it's just crazy you know
I I picked a really special song for me
because my cousin is my best friend and
so I got to write that song for her to
walk down the aisle for her wedding so
for me it was already emotional and then
I turned and I saw all these people
giving me deaf applause and then it hit
me even harder and then I turned and I
saw my parents and my husband and my
friends and my band and I was just I
lost it for Simon I just really want to
make him proud because he used his one
buzzer on on me and I I just hope I hope
that it touched people and I hope that
it was enough definitely touch people I
want to ask you what do you hope people
take away from your story I've gotten a
lot of emails and a lot of messages
thousands of thousands of people who are
hurting or they're dealing with loss and
it just has become so obvious that no
matter who you are you will deal with
something and it's so much of a hope to
know that we're all in this together and
I think that we all have a
responsibility to encourage other people
and lift them off there's such darkness
in the world why not shine some light
through anything that we can do whether
that's saying hi to a stranger or
holding the door for someone it doesn't
have to be huge but we can change the
world in small steps
[Music]
[Applause]